former White House press secretary Sean
Spicer help me out my friend first of
all great to have you on the show
congratulations thank you been a while
yeah it's good to see you what's going
on here with Rubio I mean look we
haven't had we haven't had comprehensive
tax reform in 31 years I think this is
when you have a 52 seat majority
everyone's looking for their opportunity
to get their issue highlighted their
issue addressed at the end of the day
Marco Rubio is going to be a vote for us
he is not going to let this moment
escape us and he understands how
important tax reform is but I think he
like a lot of other senators are making
sure that they get their voice heard
before
this is done Michael Lee is partnering
with him I guess I there's a couple of
other quarters
I think corker is probably one that I
would say is gone I like about what
President Trump does he forces everybody
to put the cards on yeah and I mean you
know where everybody is now corker like
I always knew that corker but basically
just couldn't stand Trump didn't want to
work with him and was going to subvert a
lot of his agenda and indeed right down
to the end corporate oh you know I'm
sorry no but but to think the big
takeaway that I look at in a day like
today when everyone's course trading is
how important that Alabama seat was know
how important our majority is because
what this comes down to is we had into
2018 if Chuck Schumer's the leader we're
not gonna be having a debate about what
tax credits or how much I want tax
relief people are getting this is why
making sure that the president maintains
a majority in the House and Senate is
crucial to keeping the President's
agenda moving forward and you think of
John McCain who's in the hospital
suffering from the glioblastoma
treatment and what it does to your body
and fat cochran is ailing he's the
senator from Mississippi
remember the Republicans rushed in there
to stave off that chris mcdaniel that
primary challenger a few years ago and i
think a lot of the populous including
ban and others thought wait a second
cochran 76 years old it's time to get a
younger person in there and you could
kind of play that game of you know more
was a mistake but you know maybe cochran
was a mistake cuz you can have a you
know a younger more vibrant senator in
there as well it plays both ways well
right now we got to concentrate on get
out fifty votes for this tax tax bill so
that the American people can enjoy the
fruits of it what about a Paul Ryan he
says next year is as last year is that
because he sees a Republican wipeout I
want to stop you right there for a
second because I think when you say you
this story was a political story
president called Paul Ryan said
need you to stay and be a partner of up
mine and help drive the agenda forward
Nepal comes out and says I want to stay
I've committed to the to getting this
agenda done Paul Ryan it hurts a policy
guy who finally sees a Republican Senate
Republican and a Republican president
and knows that he can achieve some of
those policy goals that he's worked
tirelessly for for so long
so I think one of the traps that we as
conservative have to stop getting into
every time Politico or the New York
Times throws out some clickbait that we
immediately run around assume it's true
and start planning around it Paul came
out today after the president called him
and said he's committed to saying he
wants to think there's no truth to the
public office or everyone who's been
around this for a long time you know
thinks about when they're gonna get out
or what the circumstances every night
it's a grind pilot is a grind and he's a
guy who's done it since he was 25 years
old and it takes a toll on your family
the commute off he's got a lot to be
proud of but I think he really sees the
next few years as an opportunity to get
all of these lifelong policy goals
achieved the Republicans get wiped out
next year Paul Ryan's not gonna want to
sit if they get wiped out that he's
Minority Leader but I think he
recognizes that the President's agenda
is what's going to keep the Republicans
in power and he wants to be there to
fulfill a close now I mean closer look I
think everybody understands the
president has an agenda that the
Republican base is highly supportive of
and they want to work with him and I
think the president gets that he's he's
grown into this job as someone who's an
outsider and a disrupter he's starting
to learn that some of these folks that
came about everybody at once right but
he's getting along he's getting things
done and this will be a big win for this
president in this country I know you
know Amoroso I know her a little bit
from the White House days and I was a
big deal today she was on Good Morning
America and she had this to say let's
watch as the only African American woman
in this White House as a senior staff
and assistant to the president I have
seen things that have made me
uncomfortable that have upset me that
have affected me deeply and emotionally
that has affected my community and my
people and when I can tell my story it
is a profound story but I know the world
will want to hear she is gonna be
leaving the White House
January 20th that was a big it was a big
focus of the White House briefing today
is like they never talk about Amoroso
but today like well why is she being
paid through January 20th what is like
$1500 I mean like what do you what do
you but anyway what's going on there do
you know what any inside I don't but I
think why was she hired do you think I
don't know but I think it's important
that she have any qualifications to work
in the White House I I think I think
that you know look she she was very
loyal to the president she campaign and
and I think the president brought a lot
of people who wanted to fulfill his
agenda and that's his prerogative as the
president president-elect at the time I
wish her the best but I don't I'm not
really sure what she has a story to tell
Gina did you see I don't I don't then
here you saw some well look I'll
charismatic person a colorful
charismatic individual she's big
personality I kind of like that but you
know some people can't take that I will
let you leave it at that
would you miss it you miss it you miss
the rush I mean it was exhausting it
wasn't I've talked you through
throughout a lot of that time and it is
a 1920 hour day week and you never sleep
and you never get any privacy right you
have a little bit of privacy back a
little it's growing I mean this though
it was truly an honor to do this and I
was proud to be part of helping the
president move his agenda forward I
loved being on the outside I loved being
all that be supportive from this thing
it's definitely a lot less stressful and
and so I look forward to doing a lot of
other opportunities got a book coming up
I know I'm excited about your book what
do you think that if this year when you
we look back at it objectively this year
will be seen as a successful year for
this president given where the economy
is given where consumer confidence is
yes t regulatory efforts I think I do
and I think especially if we get this
tax reform done but a lot of the things
that he's done in terms of regulatory
measures to peel back to get business
booming again to get people hired all of
those economic indicators housing starts
consumer confidence et cetera are going
through the roof and I think when people
look back objectively whether it's two
years five years ten years they're gonna
say this was a real economic powerhouse
of a year and it was the president's
policies and initiatives that really got
the economy booming again we came in and
people mocked us for talking about 3%
growth and now we're on the path so
that's become now the baseline he needs
to get the credit for that and he's not
getting the credit I think you will but
we need happy voters going into the
routine Sean great to see every
Christmas Merry Christmas I can't wait
to read your book thank you how to come
on radio and TV